Hello Psych2Go-ers!
We just want to
take the time to thank you
for all your kind of support.
We're a team of dedicated,
passionate and hardworking individuals,
who come together every day
with one goal in mind:
We want to make psychology
come alive for you.
We're self-funded
and recently launched our Patreon!
If you enjoy the work we do
and find it meaningful,
please stick around
until the end of the video
for information on
how to get more involved with us,
and all the cool rewards
you can get from us!
We hope you enjoy this video!
The world is becoming
more demanding
and fast-paced every day.
As a result, it's easy to feel
burnt-out and unmotivated.
Just when you think
you're ready to pick
yourself up again and start over,
something happens along the way
that can flip you like a switch.
It's not too long
until you find yourself sinking.
It feels heavy but it feels familiar.
You may find yourself
scared of fading,
and wanting to disappear again.
So, how do you keep going?
Here are five ways to stay motivated,
once you're ready to do something.
1. Realize what you can control,
and allow the rest
that you can't to just be.
It's powerful when you recognize
that you're in control of
how your life unfolds.
This prevents you from living passively.
We all feel lost
at some point in our lives,
and that's okay.
But when you allow
your uncertainty to do the steering,
you can easily fall into the trap
of going through everyday motions,
just because.
It's easy to give ourselves
less credit than what we deserve,
because it means taking less
responsibility for our lives.
Instead of shutting yourself away
from taking control, embrace it.
But also learn to let go
of what cannot be controlled.
Balance is key.
Have people in your life
who believe in your potential,
although it may be tempting
to want to prove
your non-believers wrong.
You may be putting yourself
at an emotional risk.
If you're going to be motivated,
be motivated by healthy reasons.
Do something because you care about.
Or, if you're feeling dejected,
do something because you
want to care about it again.
Connect with positive people
and others with similar goals,
together, we can build
a support system for one another
when the going gets tough.
Everyone falls down at some point.
What matters is finding others
who can lend a hand
to help you get back up
and try again.
3. Adapt a different perspective
towards your obstacles.
Don't be afraid of
your struggles or challenges.
Instead, build your resilience and focus
on the benefits of growing
from the mistakes you make.
Setbacks can teach you
the art of patience.
It's easy to get discouraged
when you experience bad days
or feel overwhelmed,
with things get hectic.
Life is full of surprises,
including the bad ones.
So, expect the unexpected,
but don't allow the temporary negativity
to cause you prolonged suffering.
Instead, take a step back,
and tell yourself that
the storm will pass.
4. Breakdown your big goals
into smaller ones.
It can be daunting
when you have to execute big tasks.
Rather than diving in blindly,
It's more helpful to first visualize
what you want to accomplish.
You can do this by drawing a map,
creating an outline
or coming up with a list.
When you break down a big task
into multiple small ones,
it makes it much more approachable
and much more doable.
Since there's only
24 hours in a day,
and only so much energy you carry,
before you feel burnt out
and need to recharge.
You have to recognize
the limitations you possess,
and make the best
out of your time and resources.
This will help you learn
how to prioritize accordingly.
5. Don't forget to live for yourself,
and have fun in between.
If all you're doing
is work and no fun,
Then, you're putting your mental
and physical health at risk.
Don't forget to enjoy life
for what it is.
Although it's great to find something
you're passionate about,
leave room for yourself,
to grow with your friends,
your love life and your family.
Break familiar cycles of work and routine
and replace them with laughter
or moments of joy
when you try something new.
Give yourself time to be who you are,
without your work defining you.
It doesn't make you
any less passionate.
You just make room
for valuable experiences
that remind you why
you were motivated in the first place.
How do you stay motivated
when the going gets tough?
Share your thoughts down below!
Also, don't forget to subscribe
for more content from Psych2go
and check out our Patreon!
We started it because
we want to grow into a bigger platform
that reaches more people
who are in need of help.
With your contribution,
you can receive our psy pendant,
t-shirt, issues of our magazine,
and many more membership benefits.
Your funding will help us produce
quality script writing,
voiceovers, and animation
that makes our content
both entertaining and educational.
We want to make sure
our community members
get the best and only the best.
Thanks for watching!
Hey everybody,
I just want to give a personal
thank you video for you guys
for always supporting Psych2go
and making it all possible for us.
Our vision is to make psychology
as accessible as possible
so that it promotes self-awareness
and it helps you guys grow.
However, we want to make
more content for you guys
and would love your support
and buying one of these bracelets
from our partner, introvert Palace.
Check out the bracelet,
it's pretty cool,
and it even includes Pluto!
The link to purchase will
all be in the description below,
and I hope you guys
have an amazing day!
Bye!